hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to markiplier no escape beta
version 1.0 point 3 now this is another
fan game that was made for me to play
and it's probably got a lot of internal
references that are going to be
interesting and hopefully make me
chuckle I hear noises well don't we all
that's pretty much a generic sweeping
statement I need to grab the candle
before I leave
well you shouldn't tell me what to do
there me so why don't you show up your
attitude and then shut up you check
inside the closet but something or
someone pushes it and falls on you what
already how could I have died already
what did i do what did I do wrong I
can't exactly yell in proclamation cuz
my voice is still recuperating from its
ordeal this weekend well that's not fair
alright fine you're gonna be that way
I guess it's gonna be a trolling game I
hear noises well I need to grab the
candle before I leave what if I check
the other closet is it also going to
kill me
yeah that's gonna kill me too I'm gonna
work I'm gonna operate on to your
subject everything in this game is gonna
kill me and it's really dramatic when I
die like that I'd like to think that
even if a closet did follow me I
wouldn't just instantly scream like that
and then kick the bucket I need to
control my voice because I still need to
record a lot more before I Mauer this
however I can't even talk anyway so why
should I bother no that you as what I
said if I was a raspy old war veteran
okay were you screaming it's a note is
it gonna kill me I will kill you okay
just like you killed me all those years
ago I have already started before with
your sister didn't know I had a sister
didn't you hear her scream not in
recognized voice she thought you would
save her she thought you would come but
you didn't you couldn't protect your
mark and now it's your turn don't go in
the Attic no escape once again don't
tell me what to do I'm going straight up
into that attic now okay what'd you say
imagine this guy's gonna kill me who are
you you sound a bit off-key alright then
wait a minute oh come on off-key was
that a clue did you just change up my
control scheme Mouse but okay screw you
what the hell did you do
really oh God really it oh well
I'll be right back this is gonna be my
general rule thumb don't touch anything
don't do anything don't interact with
anything and above all else just don't
die it looks like a delicious cake over
there he's gonna kill me
I imagine the answer is yes oh that's
not even a real note okay how about the
grant dog nope no I can't even interact
with it
well they said don't go in the Attic so
I'm gonna be sure to actually do that do
you want to go upstairs absolutely I do
wait a minute wait a minute something
ain't right here there's nothing here
oh that's actually quite ominous you
can't escape
well that would be the name of the game
oh come on I could've easily escaped it
did there was a ladder right there that
it came up from what are you going to
tell me that I just suddenly forget how
to use a ladder I mean I know there's me
we're talking about here but I do have
some brain cells left I hear noises
again I need to take that candle again
okay so in addition to doing the obvious
this might be a 50/50 choice here you'll
need to get the basement key first okay
how do I get that and why are there a
bunch of robbers in my house are they
the ones who are killing my sister it's
a note
dearest markiplier I hope you do
remember what you did to me all those
years ago
when you killed me you didn't just leave
me dead but left a scar where my heart
was would this all matter if you were
dead why did you do this to me I wanted
to be with you alright
creepy okay alright alright alright
alright so what is this a creepy stalker
I remember now
what do I remark I'm scared I'm going to
be trapped down here forever maybe shut
up shut up nurse okay this is how this
relationship is starting off three days
later did I eat her did I eat her or
something no senses I did eat her I ate
her I ate my nurse I'm so sorry there
was another choice I I literally ate my
nurse okay what if only it was me if
only I could eat me
I'm tasty delicious I remember so no I
ate my nurse I think it's what I'm
trying to take from that whew alright
this nice looks familiar
I just can't think why well I probably
used it to butcher my nurse if you know
what I mean what's cooking my head
okay I thought it was gonna kill me
again wait can I save yes I can
thank goodness at least I won't have to
go through all that again now all right
hello plant have you seen any dirt oh
that's that's looks like dirt kind of
earthy like dirt if you haven't seen
that animation it's over there it's from
Lucius Lucius created two animations out
of that rather bland game came to
animation it's a picture of Wade's mom
oh and what do we have here there's a
tunnel want to go through not yet let me
say it before I do that
yup dig all right let's go clean huh ooh
this looks deadly
Oh surprisingly not all right then whoo
hello baby are you doing hey baby you
study the statue closely oh yes I do
you received the basement key well good
for me then that's uh good right I'm
assuming hey baby you study the stitch
you oh so close
I've activated a trap okay in order to
save yourself answer these five
questions correctly are they about me
question 1 what was markiplier his first
video about well actually my first video
was about uh amnesia it was a my first
video ever on my other channel was
amnesia the Dark Descent part 1 but on
this channel is compilation what is
markiplier is full name Oh God
I don't know clean
when was Mark born oh god I don't know
quite correct
what color is Mark's mustache I don't
have one quite correct
what did mark accuse Bob of having on
his two terabyte hard drive two
terabytes of porn I want to say animal
pee noir but how could anybody have two
terabytes of animal pee nor if you have
two terabytes of animal pee nor on your
hard drive not only common in the
description below or comments below but
seek professional help unless you are a
professional animal pee nor expert no
wait how would I say on Bob's 2 terabyte
hard drive that there was one terabyte
of porn I wouldn't have said gay porn I
don't think maybe it was animal pee nor
that does sound like something I do yeah
it was a correct answer
oh man my voice is really going now this
might be the last video recorded today I
meant to do more don't tell me this is
also trap ooh
markiplier ultimate skill there's what
we under magic when needed thank you
baby
thank you for giving me my ultimate
skill you know how to sensually caress
my every need not that caressing
people's needs is something that's
commonly done but you know wait a minute
this is different
never mind it's absolutely not different
I lied okay I'll leave the room with the
picture of Wade's mom but with much
regret I will come back for you AIDS mom
now Wade's mom was a sweet lady alright
what do we got here woody got in store
from a game hello mister man so what am
I supposed to do about you
oh I see he's on a following mechanic
well we're gonna just see about that I
can run I did not know this this
knowledge was lost to me all right any
more bookshelves gonna come tumbling
down on my head let's see
hello hello a minds are supposed to go
on the holy ground and the hole in the
ground right now I suppose so
yes absolutely I love to jump blindly
and holes it what did you leave me for
dead I don't think I did I'm pretty sure
that I hate you why are you doing this
nurse because I loved you but you didn't
love me you just wanted me dead
shut up nurse that's why I have the best
revenge plan ever really this basement
that we were trapped in in my own home
that you were stuck in and then revenged
upon me I've decided that I'll send
empty boxes of Jesus to your house for
the rest of your miserable life no how
many are we talking here
whoa no I wish I could scream no to the
heavens you'll just have to take a
monotone No prepare to die nurse this is
a rather extreme reaction don't you
think I seem like the violet douchebag
here don't I whoa I didn't know my nurse
look like that a succubus uh-huh well
Mark's electro-pulse okay well I guess
I'm done then all right well that was
easy
hmm oh no nurse I'm so sorry I regret
congratulations mark you've finished the
Hellspawn your vanished the Hellspawn
back into the surgeon simulator you have
saved yourself from empty boxes of
cheeses however at the cost of your
non-existent sister I think I'll get
over this burden you are too pro is
there nothing you can't accomplish
double negative just wait until the
Apple comes out you won't be laughing
for long I wasn't laughing but I will
now hoo ha hee ha ho ho dear markiplier
my name is Michael Rodriguez I'm a huge
fan I know this sounds corny but I have
to say this this game may not be good at
all however in my first game I wanted to
be noticed by you even if that means
making crap a game like this I'm going
to call next year to be a game art
designer I would have done never decide
if it weren't for your videos you were
the best
with your career on YouTube in your
donation Michael Rodriguez thank you so
much Michael it was actually a lot of
fun I always loved playing these fan
games to get the little references out
of it and to be able to read what you
have to say I really do appreciate you
guys making me this game and also I know
that there's some games out there made
for me that I have not played yet so if
you guys might not done with this game
oh wait I came oh okay
so yes let me know if there's any other
games that people have made for me that
I haven't found out about send me an
email send me a message on Twitter or
like notify me on Twitter or whatever
way you can to give me the Jimmy I'd
love to play these games because I
really love the fact that people go out
of their way to make me a game so thank
you everybody so much for watching check
out the other games that fans have made
for me in the link in the description
below there's a whole playlist of them
and over the annotations over there
thanks again everybody for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye it's come to my attention
that your dick
marks doing business is very pervasive
if you didn't know especially in the
Fishbach how people don't even know my
last name
how'd you hear you